[Musique]
du nouveau dans l'affaire de
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty la cour
d'appel de Paris a confirmé le renvoi de
14 personnes en procès du major seront
jugés devant les assis spéciales deux
amis de la saillant pour complicité
d'assassinat terroriste 6 autres
personnes pour association de malfaiteur
terroristes criminels enfin 5 mineurs
accusés notamment d'avoir désigné Samuel
Paty à l'assaillant seront jugés devant
le tribunal pour enfants tout comme une
sixième adolescente elle pour
dénonciation calomnieuse il s'agit de
l'élève à l'origine du mensonge sur la
teneur d'un cours de Samuel Paty auquel
elle n'avait pas assisté le 16 octobre
2020 l'enseignant d'histoire-géographie
avait été poignardée puis décapité près
de son collège du bois d'aulne à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine le terroriste
avait été abattu par les forces de
l'ordre l'ancien président de la
République Nicolas Sarkozy était de
passage dans les Yvelines hier mercredi
13 septembre il est venu dédicacer son
deuxième livre sur ses mémoires dans la
librairie Gibert Versailles intitulé Le
Temps des combats il revient sur ses
années à l'Élysée
c'est pas tellement la suite c'est le
continuum du lien que j'ai avec les
Français
c'est l'histoire d'événements qu'on a
vécu ensemble et qui ont laissé de
grandes traces pour moi et qui je
l'espère ont laissé des trash c'est chez
tous ceux qui me lisent et c'est
toujours un bonheur de rencontrer les
lecteurs les chauffeurs de bus Keolis
sont lancé une grève illimitée depuis
mardi dernier il bloque l'entrée du site
de Montesson leur principal
revendication la réhabilitation de leur
prime d'intéressement et de
participation supprimées depuis 2022 ce
mouvement impact plus d'une dizaine de
lignes sur 90 chauffeurs 8 seraient non
grévistes ce soir l'équipe de France de
rugby affronte l'Uruguay pour son
deuxième match de Coupe du monde même si
la rencontre se joue à Lille vous pouvez
soutenir les Bleus dès 21h en direct des
Yvelines plusieurs villes du département
se sont mises aux couleurs du XV de
France comme Rambouillet et Versailles
ou des écrans géants ont été installés